Oh welcome the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am marking our
oh [ __ ] boy we all sound sad don't we
but this isn't a night to mourn this is
a night to celebrate and remember and
that's what we're gonna do in a minute
before we dive into that hold that
thought just want to thank everybody if
you're watching at home or listening at
home if we are every as we are every
week here in the scum and villainy
canteen on Hollywood Boulevard put your
hands together so the folks at home know
you're real the beautiful thing is this
place is sold out at because they're a
bunch of people want to be together on
this day for an Irish wake we've all
gathered to honor the sensational
Stanley this evening ladies and
gentlemen and we're gonna do that we're
tell fun [ __ ] stories our remembrances
and then turn to you guys and see if you
guys got any remembrances so if anybody
has ever encountered or met Stanley and
I'm sure almost half this room if not
everybody in this room probably
interacted with them at one point or
another took a picture with them saw
medic on or whatever the [ __ ] have those
ready that's what we'll be doing at the
end of the night instead of Q&A we're
gonna just keep talking about Stan and
rather than just it'd be me and Mark
we're gonna turn it over to you guys as
well because we think a lot of people
feel what we feel man we got to spend a
little time with the minutes life time I
got to spend a lot of time with him in
the last 23 years so I was quatre
cataloging it's weird I've never done
this before but I started writing down
all the moments I can remember that I
interacted with them and I came up with
a long [ __ ] list Wow
so I'm gonna have a lot of stories to
tell cuz it's gonna read like a [ __ ]
journal that Kevin Spacey kept in seven
just not that he keeps in real life
that's that's a different thing
altogether
it's tough making Kevin Spacey movie
references anymore man I'm trying to be
good man and trying goddamn it sucks
how the boys I've loved before so we're
gonna talk about Stan we're gonna love
on Stan tonight it's weird this is the
first time we've done this show in a
Stanley las' world I thought about that
this morning when I woke up put it up on
Instagram this is the first morning in
my life that I've woken up in a Stan
Leela swirled and it is a little less
[ __ ] colorful and there's a long tale
that that wonderful dinosaur are left
behind that we'll all be riding from now
until the end of time like Fred
Flintstone at the five o'clock whistle
and [ __ ] he'll be here forever will
he'll he'll be with us in the movies
from what I understand for at least five
more Marvel films they shot a bunch of
cameos in one hit in advance so you know
it but and his characters will be with
us forever the he's he's gone but he's
not going anywhere no he's a legend now
he's an icon he belongs to Eternity but
it's [ __ ] weird just to think that
the whole [ __ ] that's it like the trail
ends here except not really but that's
the great part is that because like I
wrote this piece for The Hollywood
Reporter today just sort of kind of
eulogizing kind of just explained it to
people who aren't quite as familiar with
Stanley despite all the work what he
meant to the industry and I am I I was
doing some research and it stunned me
that he started writing monthly comics
in 1961 and he stopped in 1972 and in
that time he created everything like
most of the [ __ ] Marvel Universe was
done in the decade like and I think
that's probably the single greatest
creative burst in pop culture history
like nobody else has done quite as much
that has legs as that 10-year run and
also you know people could point to of
course the distinguished competition
DC's got but they they don't have a
stand they have many creators under one
roof but Stan in concert with many
brilliant artists and and other writers
as well created
so many [ __ ] characters or what
people nowadays call IP like [ __ ]
intellectual property you're right
like mark millar comes close in terms of
not even close but he's the next guy I
can think of in terms of like wow he
created a bunch of [ __ ] over the span of
a decade
he's very prolific and Kirby also like
when she went over to DC and when she
was Unchained and absolutely went to
[ __ ] town you know like there's a
bunch of people who did that I mean I
always think of like Rod Serling's run
on the Twilight Zone as maybe the single
greatest television feat ever because he
wrote half of 200 episodes by himself
Wow and all of them are short stories
like there are no recurring characters
there's no recurrent plot likely just
that amount of invention to make the
twilight zone work is astonishing but
none of them had to have legs like none
of those characters in those little
episodes needed to carry from one
episode to the next when you create you
know [ __ ] Spider Man when you create
fantastic for those characters have to
be strong enough to carry story for
decades and that's the thing but not
only did he invent these characters but
he built a framework for story that
allowed us to keep telling stories about
those characters for decades since and
that's no [ __ ] small feat I often
refer to him head to his face over the
course of the last 23 years particularly
more in the last 10 years than anything
else
and I'll probably be saying it you know
until the dad die he's kind of like a
modern-day Mark Twain I used to say he's
the Mark Twain of comic books and then I
was like now he's just the modern-day
Mark Twain but when you put up how
prolific he was against Mark Twain I
think he's still he beats Mark Twain as
well yeah I mean if he was writing 10
books a month for 10 years that's a lot
of [ __ ] books and even the writing
that Stan was doing which was hey Steve
here's what spider-man's gonna do this
month he's gonna swing on a web and he's
gonna save the girl and punch me Stewie
in the face and then Steve Ditko will go
off and draw that [ __ ] and bring it back
and he would then write the dialogue for
it all like the way I read comics is I'm
writing 22 pages of comic and somebody's
drawing 20 suppose a comic you wrote a
paragraph was like go off and do that
but he still had to write all the
dialogue and
after time the art that came back was
not the paragraph he sent off so go [ __ ]
that's a helicopter crash in this and
we're in Vietnam now all right I guess
and somebody is on drugs sure okay we
can see why not and like just having a
stitch that [ __ ] together and then do
that for ten books in a month like it's
an astonishing amount of work for one
guy to do I do well that's the weird
thing is like he had them of course
everybody there's a generation of kids
who gnome is like that spider-man's
daddy or something like that but they
know him from the movies but they don't
you know and they know from their
parents like he seems to be something
that's been passed down my dad passed
Stanley down to me as well like you know
I I knew Stanley's named from the books
I knew his voice before I ever heard his
voice because he was very vocal in his
comics in the editorial section in
Stan's soapbox and stuff like that but I
remember first time I saw him I heard
his voice as a kid
they give was on like the Today Show or
Good Morning America or something like
that and my father was like keV come in
here and I went into the living room and
he's like that's Stanley and I said
spider-man Stanley and he said yes and
we sat there and watched it together and
it was this weird like we know this
together this is information that we
share I don't know it seems now that
that's what happens I've read it a bunch
of people you know I put up a Instagram
post they're a bunch of wonderful
comments and the threads and not
comments like hey good job but comments
these wonderful stories where people
talk about like I would sit there with
my dad and watch these movies for the
last 10 years and when he showed up on
screen abit like there is there's like
Stanley and like I read that and I was
like [ __ ] I know that like I just I know
what it's like to be able to share
something with a parent that you think
is [ __ ] vastly important and the
parent thing is important for a
different reason altogether my old man
was just like there's a guy who
makes comic books for a living in that
something like he thought that was just
impressive but me I'm like yeah but he's
so much more than that
so I it's he seems to be something
that's now passed down from generation
to generation kind of like Mark Twain I
guess right like crazy
yeah everybody will have a different
piece of him and what that piece meant
to that you know for if you're 12 years
old going to the movies like oh there's
the dude who's in all the movies I've
seen that guy he's kind of funny he's
got a really good one-liner he called
Tony Stark Tony stank once that was cool
you know for for people our age you came
to the Marvel Universe as readers in the
70s and 80s like he was the face of
comics he was the one guy you could put
a name on who said that guy makes comics
you didn't I mean even if maybe you knew
Frank Miller from drawing daredevil
maybe you knew Julie Schwartz just cos
you went to a convention so I mentioned
his name but you would never see any of
those guys on TV on the radio like
reppin it I mean and and I really think
that Stan in a way gave birth to modern
fandom in that he he built a
relationship with that brand unlike any
relationship we'd ever had with a brand
before you know like you would read a
Marvel comic it was make mind Marvel
don't be like Brand X you know the guys
across the street you're a Marvel reader
you're not a DC read you read anything
but the distinguished competition the
distinguished competition like to marry
Marvel March we identify the no prize
the man who invented the no prize that's
in the envelope the no prize empty but
like you became a Marvel person like
that was that was part of your identity
you stoke the flames of fan I like
Marvel not DC I like this not like that
like who goes around saying I like
Paramount not Universal you know like
just people can make movies and you go
to the movies but he was like no I only
want these books these are the books
that speak to me these are the books
that tell stories that I feel I relate
to and and DC as good as they might have
been in the 70s and 80s English 50s and
60s like they gave us the first
superhero but they never gave us that
sense of belonging though he got from
Marvel and some of that's because
they're writing about teenagers some of
it's because they were writing about
misfits all of which you had problems
and anxieties and just
struggling with angst and how do I pay
the bills and how do I talk to that girl
and how do I do all of this shouldn't
save the world of what happens when I
come home and I can't pay my rent like
that was not a thing in DC books until
it was the more books no in DC books
they were just like look at this poor
boy billionaire now will he get over the
grief of losing his parents he's a bat
what up boy crazy the Marvel formula was
was science gone nuts right because they
post atomic bomb their Atomic Age
characters so everything is like a
science based mishap that happens to a
real person
they II believed in telling the story of
the man or the woman more than the
Superman or the superwoman like tell
that story first which is something
which is Apes now in like programming
all those CW shows they try to tell you
the story of the person not the super
you know listen first and then later on
I like [ __ ] the boy will run very
fast to solve his problems of [ __ ] like
there was the rare 60s 70s Marvel hero
who was from outer space you know like
they were all from [ __ ] Brooklyn or
from Queens or from the Bronx or from
Hell's Kitchen like there were all
people for whom something happened like
nobody crashed in a comet nobody is
phased in from another dimension they
were just [ __ ] people yeah you know
and they were just kids who's like the
the unlucky luck of having a gene that
went wonky and suddenly I can shoot
through schools with my eyes and
suddenly I can't touch anybody and oh
[ __ ] like I what do I do when the world
hates me because of who I am that what I
do what year was x-men 63 so he's
creating from what 61 to 780 72 72 what
is one of the last things he does I
don't know if it's a black panther black
panther was 60 something like panther
was was relatively early 68 I don't know
the last thing he did I mean I might
have been Squirrel Girl
that was Jack right maybe but it was
also Stan really yeah it sounds like a
standing squirrel girl run with it we
did the radioactive thing like nine
times
what did she get bitten by I first time
I met him was on the set of mall rats
first time I heard him though was on the
phone prior to that that guy had written
I told the story zillion times but I
wrote the script for mall rats first
draft and sent it to Jim Jack's he was
the producer one of the producers and I
said you know he read it he called me up
instance stuff and he goes this is funny
he's going who's this one character you
wrote that you know Brody gets advice
from I said well you know he's like
meant to be like a Stanley like what the
most famous name in comic books and
stuff and he's like well I'll just write
it for Stanley I was like no Stanley
he's like why do and I was like
Hollywood is good they know each other
here and [ __ ] who else do you know Bach
so I said well I asked him if he wants
me know he's God well I'll ask him I'm
going out to Dan Tana's with the next
week and [ __ ] so he asks him and he
calls me back ago Stan is interested he
wants to do it he loves to act I was
like oh my god I'm fantastic let me
rewrite the scenes so I rewrote the
scenes now knowing it's Stanley and
stuff sent it to fax those pages because
it was like five pages to jim jacks he
read the scene and stuff he goes I'm
gonna send it on a stand
he sends I understand I talked to Jim
Jack's the next day so what'd he say he
and his best [ __ ] Stanley impression
Jim Jack's goes his exact quote was this
I would never say this [ __ ]
[Music]
and since we lost something it goes no
no no he's gone I talked him down told
him is a movie his movie stand he said
but he got one request for you I said
really cuz yeah he's gonna ask himself
Oh what what do you mean he's gone your
your call him he's gonna ask you this
question then he'll tell you whether or
not he could be in the movie and I was
like okay get a phone call I'm Stanley
Kevin Smith yes this is Stanley I was
like I know oh my god I'm a huge fan my
whole life I and one end to the usual
spiel and he was like thank you he's I
could tell that you were a fan based on
these pages he's go but listen you have
me telling this boy a story and it's a
story about the one that got away but I
don't have one that got away I got one
and she's at home and if I say these
things in a movie she's not gonna let me
come home it's adorable a 72 year old
man still gave a [ __ ] that his wife
would be mad at him and stuff so I was
like oh I understand he goes so what I
need you to do is if can you write a
scene where afterwards like I say that
it was all a joke or something and I was
like oh my god yeah sure absolutely
exactly what it that's what it takes you
to say yeah alright any [ __ ] scene
yeah so in the movie you know he runs
into TS of T as it's like a man you do
it and you get the impression that TS
sets stand up for it and stuff and that
was because of Stan
like that scene exists because he he
didn't want to upset his wife and you
know he was like I'm playing myself in
the movie it's a weird line right so he
was like I want to make sure that
everybody knows that Stan Lee would
never have had had this happen because
he married the love of his life of the
stuff really really adorable so I said
absolutely I could write that and he
said then I'll see you on set he goes
I'll see you in Hollywood but he didn't
know we were shooting in [ __ ]
Minnesota so
I've turned out to be another discussion
where Jim was just like yeah man Stan
didn't know that we were out here in
Minneapolis I think he tried to back out
he goes well you know it's cold out here
by 73 years old he was 73 man and there
was at that time 1995 like we better do
this quick the man's old but he lived
another 23 [ __ ] years you couldn't
you couldn't stop the guy so I meet him
on set first day the day that we shoot
the scene with him and man he was just
[ __ ] everything that you'd hoped he
was charming he was affable who's lovely
told the same stories I'd heard at Comic
Cons and read and comics and stuff I
wanted repetition from Stan Lee the idea
that like sometimes you just can't
assume that everybody has heard the
[ __ ] story like his whole thing with
comics was just like you got to write a
comic book like it's somebody's first
comic book every comic book is gonna be
somebody's first comic book so it has to
be able to appeal to a brand-new reader
not just like the people who know the
story so you got to repeat yourself
sometimes he repeated himself many times
man but you know it was part of his
charm it's like oh he's telling this
story again here we go you know and
settle in and stuff and it was a well
told tale so he was wonderful on set we
had cue cards because again the man was
like 73 and stuff and unlike these
current Marvel movies that he was cameo
in him where they give him one line he
had a [ __ ] scene he had a boatload of
dialogue and stuff so we had big ol
big-ass cue cards there's only one real
cut in the movie we could see him kind
of look away from Brody the rest of the
time he's looking right at him whatever
once in a while he'd have to glance off
to the side and stuff like that he if
you watch that scene it's really
beautiful he has this wonderful delivery
talking about you know this girl this
fictional girl that was like I've kind
of took a scene from Citizen Kane where
one of the gentlemen talks about seeing
this woman you know on a train and like
he'd not a day goes by he doesn't think
of that woman he wishes he had said
something to her and stuff so I kind of
adapted that stole that homage and stole
it
and so that's what he was doing so he's
walking
you know his line he goes take care and
he walks away from Brody and he's
heading off in this direction
and so Brody goes stand and he turns
right yeah and he goes she really meant
that much to you and Stan's got
wonderful delivery really serious nailed
it in one take he goes Brody I'd give it
up I'd give it all up all of it for just
one more day with her take care and then
he turns around and walks in the
opposite [ __ ] direction of the way
was going so Mosier at that time it goes
did we do another take I was like [ __ ]
no don't worry about it
that was beautiful I'm giving you which
way he's going and [ __ ] he hung out we
took pictures Walter Flanagan who I you
know loved comic books with and then
later on did comic book men with which
Stan appeared on multiple times it was a
big day for us when he came to set
because he was like oh [ __ ] I'm bringing
all my books and he's signing everything
and I was like don't use of me 73 for
Christ sakes but we took pictures with
him and not like we you know this was
not the days of selfies because nobody
had their own cameras and stuff
thankfully there was a guy on set set
photographer on set photographer Carlos
on top I believe his name was who was
taking pictures of us with Stan so
there's you can find it online there's a
picture of you know him sitting in the
director's chair and making spider-man
hands and I'm behind him making
spider-man hands with like a weird goofy
grin it's something we replicated like
years later which I just threw up on
Instagram today so that was my first
experience with the guy and when he was
done shooting he was just like now you
got to put me in all your movies and I
was like okay and then that movie died
but I remember we when the premiere
happened he was at the premiere party
like MTV did a premiere special and he
was there on camera he was like one of
the biggest celebrities there you know
the cast went on to become famous and
stuff like Affleck and [ __ ] but at the
time like Michael Rooker was pretty
famous because he was in Henery portrait
of a serial killer
and Stan was famous because he was
Stanley and stuff so after that I I'd
see him at wizard Khan's all the time
like I'd go to a lot of wizard cons it
seemed at San Diego as well but I
remember we saw him at his 96 or 97
wizard Con in Chicago we were on the
floor and we had a booth USQ booth and
me and Muse or sitting there signing and
then Stan came over it was a boys a
mirror like Stan because we'd worked
with him and stuff and we chit-chatted
and then he had this signing that was
right next to us where you had to go up
three steps and you were on a stage and
so you know he was like I'm gonna do a
signing you guys come up and sign with
me and we're like oh okay he goes up you
know that stairs do the signing we sign
with it for a little bit then we go back
to our booth he's done with the signing
and he calls it off to us from the top
of the stairs
boys I'm heading off now look I had Stan
we'll see you goes what are you doing
tonight we were like I think we're going
to the steak house it goes I'll see you
there with joe cassano
and Sarah I gotta see you there turns
and proceeds to walk off the stage
without the stairs and go right to the
[ __ ] ground and this at point we made
Mallrats in 95 he's 73 this is two years
later so he's 75 man and at that point I
was like I think we just witnessed the
end of Stanley
so I mean next week true believers I
swear to you this man was a power Walker
I forgot about that my friend Vincent
Pereira reminded me today he texted me
yesterday he was like man I remember
like it felt like yesterday I was power
walking with him in the mall then he was
a PA on the flick and stand like was a
power Walker and he was like oh this is
fantastic it's a mall you know so he
gets him what mall Walker and [ __ ]
so Vinnie was tasked with like you stay
with this guy and then he's big
complaint at the end of the night was
like my [ __ ] calves her he's fast so
he brought up he was just like I
remembered just mall walking with him
like all throughout the production felt
like yesterday so he was healthy and
[ __ ] fit even at 75 and at 75 was
probably in better shape than I was at
that age which was like 28 or whatever
the [ __ ] Stan goes down we go up from
our seats like and instantly as if he
was a [ __ ] cartoon bendable he pops
right back up and he's just like I'm
okay
dusted himself off excelsior and then
walked away what do you got I got tons
I'm sure you got I only ever met him
once get out of here I swear to god it
was a 2008 at San Diego comic-con okay
and I had been writing comics for
Wildstorm for about it for about a year
I sold my first couple of books the
highwayman and then book called push to
Gimli like in gym sort of became a
little bit of a mentor I've talked about
my harassing Gimli story and don't do
that he really doesn't like you get one
and I was the one who took the I'm gonna
email Gimli for a year and beg him to
listen to my pitch and he did and he's
like you just ruined it for everybody
everybody you [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
and so I'm at San Diego I went to some
rooftop party as it does in San Diego
and it was at 10:00 10:30 11 o'clock I
was done it was like a Thursday so I had
two more days of crazy pants going on so
I'm on my way out
a Daughtry is playing on the stage
because it was 2008 that's how that goes
and and I see Gimli come in as I'm
leaving because Jim is probably 10 years
older than I am
there's more energy than anybody I've
ever met like Jim Lee is just like a
[ __ ] dynamo and what do you do I'm
just coming here I got two more parties
after this but I wanted to come I don't
want to pay homage like to who it's like
Stan sixth Ann's here so yeah you ever
meet Stan said no Jim I've never met
Stan come on let's go meet Stan so I'm
walking with [ __ ] Gimli weaving
through this party and we end
but some Cabana like off in the distance
and you know stand at this point is 85 I
guess 10 years ago and he's kind of it's
late at night he's kind of sitting in
this Cabana and he sees Jim and like it
turns on in a second it's like Jim how
are you and Jim says hey it's really
good to see you stand stand if you're
from it mark no mark this is Stan Lee
and Stan goes no relation I was like you
know what good for you old man like we
didn't say much cuz he's like listen I
gotta go I got a wall-to-wall schedule
tomorrow and if you hadn't heard I'm 85
years old so I'm just gonna say a couple
of howdy dues and go but just like I got
to [ __ ] shake the dude's hand and for
a minute I got to say hey thanks that
was amazing and I know if I went right
true believers that gotta go to sleep I
gotta be everyone each everybody did
everybody like who met him like to thank
him yeah particularly in the later years
right but that's what I saw at cons but
I even I did it in 95 when I met him so
you imagine it was going on back then
and even prior to that as well that's
what you felt you felt gratitude for the
guy because you know I imagined two
people do it now he's like I [ __ ]
love those movies and those characters
and you're in those movies you created
those characters but for us the readers
it was thanks for that thanks for the
moral compass you know you got to
remember I was a Catholic school kid and
I guarantee you my morality didn't come
from the Catholic Church came from
reading comic books
Stan Lee fashioned my morality he taught
me it was better be a good guy than a
bad guy like very simple morality tales
way more entertaining than the comic
book that I was reading in church
you know way way more adventures no more
punching yeah way more villains -
there's only one villain in that other
book so uh yeah I get it I get why you
won thank you yeah and you know like I
don't think there has been a more
perfectly crafted distillation of what
American morality is then with great
power must also come great
responsibility yeah like to a certain
degree that's that's what this country
should be when it's at its best is we
have great power we have more power than
any other country on the planet we have
more resources or manpower more
innovation all that [ __ ] but the
responsibility has to come with that so
it's a scalable morale also it's for you
in this street like if you can help
somebody you should if you got a little
bit of money you should help if you you
can lift the thing off a guy you should
like you should do the things you can do
within your power and it scales up like
as a community as a state as a country
as a world if you have the power to do
something you should do it and do it
wisely
and as a kid like it was it was George
Lucas and Chuck Jones and Stan Lee like
and that's that's how I built my moral
compass and it's it was not the good
book Chuck Jones yeah what I like
Roadrunner
bro hard-working yeah absolutely and
[ __ ] Bugs Bunny was from the Bronx
I'm from the Bronx like with a little
wit with a little Verve like you can get
anywhere that's adorable I am adorable
all right let's see what else I got
written down here man we're gonna tell
me a story I'm gonna tell you a story
I'm now with bated breath waiting for an
army hammer story oh [ __ ] they've heard
the story apparently and I still it's
true I told mark we're in the alleyway
before in the green room before the show
and
we spared no expense feeling again there
was a jeopardy of marc hearing it for
the first time I was like everyone
[ __ ] shut up so we can hear it fresh
on the show and then we've skipped it up
until now thank you for reminding me
Armie Hammer the actor yes who I've
interviewed for on IMDB seemed like a
really cool guy and I still think he's
you know I'm not like kill him after
this he's still a good guy but this I
thought was poorly timed between we're
just stupid he put up a tweet that was
to the effect of like you know it's so
nice that everyone shows you know their
condolences for Stanley by putting up
all their photos of themselves with
Stanley and so you know a bunch of
people were like man [ __ ] you you peach
[ __ ] eatin [ __ ] I saw that movie you
know [ __ ] it people got shitty [ __ ] you
Lone Ranger and then and then you know
he seemed this tweet seemed to have a
lot of likes so it seemed like a bunch
of people agreed with him is your ratio
was still yeah I don't know I didn't
read I didn't go honestly that deep on
it cuz when I read the tweet I was like
oh you don't get it man like maybe he
just don't get it give him the bed of
the duck cuz he's like didn't they get
through or he's [ __ ] obtuse but it's
like that's that's the rich tapestry
that the man woven this lifetime is like
so many [ __ ] people have photos with
him he was he never said no wasn't one
of these [ __ ] pricks that like hey
man can I take big denyin got time they
[ __ ] walk away Stan would take the
time many a he'd go to a con and you
could pay and take the time with him as
well and that was more recent but like
for [ __ ] most of his life if you just
rolled by me like all guys take a bit of
course he'd stop to take picture with me
and stuff like that so I didn't read
that as like oh this gross everyone's
cashing in on Stan I was like that's
that stand to a tee like he [ __ ] look
look at look at all these photos look at
how happy everybody who's standing next
to him is
like they're meeting [ __ ] Santa Claus
by way of Jesus Christ so I thought
armie hammer was way off on that it's
like it just read like you don't have a
picture with Stanley do you are me
hammer you know jealous much Bob it's
funny I saw this thing online today it's
it's ittle tangentially get back there
there was this clip out of Denmark and
they did the social experiment well they
took a bunch of people from different
places in Denmark like here's a bunch of
guys who were raised on a farming people
have never seen a cow here's people who
live in the city here's people in the
country here's people who were you know
[ __ ] jocks and and theater people and
they put everybody little boxes and they
said you know you were all choose to
consider yourselves one thing and that's
how you sort of go through life but then
they start asking questions like which
of your stepparents like which of you
were bullies in high school which of you
were bullied in high school and then
just watching people from these boxes
drift away and then collide with other
people who were in other separate boxes
it was basically showing we are all far
more alike than we'd like to think we
are but if you confront them with here's
the thing that you're all sort of in
touch with then you can begin to have
honest conversations about where you're
going and what you're feeling and how we
can connect in ways when it's easier to
divide and it feels like this weird
photo experiment is that Stan Lee is the
point of light that connects all of
these people maybe who would never ever
have any connection never have any
commonality but if you look at Instagram
you look at Twitter and you see this
wall of people and half of that picture
is identical and half of it is somebody
who does not look like anybody else and
those other pictures doesn't come from
someplace else as these other pictures
like Stan Lee is the the Nexus through
which he's the constant he's the
constant he's the he's the you know the
hand up on the [ __ ] window not
Penny's boat but is Stan Lee and we all
can sort of draw that the hand on the is
that a Titanic reference lost
lost yeah I thought you were saying like
the sex scene when Kate Winslet is
walking I was like was that Zeus Stanley
because she wanted to be drawn like
those french girls and who better
Yoshio who's a homage to Stan and Jack
Betsy all right let's see what else I
got so I'm at Wizard cons for a long
time oh we did Stanley's Marvel's
mutants and monsters that happened when
I first I think when I was moving out
here when I was working on the maybe we
weren't post on Jay and Silent Bob
strike back yeah I think so or maybe
this was right after that because it was
right around like post September 11th I
think Jay and Silent Bob strike back had
come out or was just about to come out
right around like came out in August
September 11th happened like a month
later I want to say that like this was
slightly after September 11th then came
out like a few months after that they
had gotten in touch with me the
production company they were like we
need somebody to interview Stanley and
you've worked with Stanley would you
like to sit down and interview him then
I was like oh my god yeah what's it for
though like we're just gonna make a DVD
of Stan talking about Marvel history and
he asked if you would do it he said he
did a movie with you and I was like I
did Mallrats the guy goes never heard of
it he's gone but Stan requested you and
so I was like oh my god I'd love to so
we went to I believe it was shot at
hidey-ho the comic store in Santa Monica
if I remember correctly but what I
remember most about it is other than how
wonderful he was like what a fantastic
storyteller you're talking about a guy
who knew how to be Stan Lee at that
point in his sleep he was so [ __ ]
good at it
i if you watched the DVD I'm
interviewing them and here I'll do an
impression of me interviewing Stan Lee
tell me a story
I'm Stan Lee yeah no you're mark barnard
oh I'm me yeah oh okay
so so I once I stole a bike
because it felt like a good idea and I
and I drove it around crack high school
just before graduation [ __ ] up tracks
all over the field oh my god and then
the next day they went to set up chairs
and she hadn't wondered who the hell was
the [ __ ] who drove their bike all
over the field watch the video I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing and the
whole time I'm like huh huh huh cuz I'm
like I gotta [ __ ] let him know that
I'm locked in and since then I've course
learned like you could do that
worthlessly as well would just like
Silent Bob in like you know so you're
not [ __ ] ohan through the whole
[ __ ] interview but that DVD just like
him being in Mallrats lent me this like
come the comic book community
credibility that I would not have had
otherwise
like clerks didn't have anything about
comic books in it really there's one
shot where they're sitting on the on the
counter where Randall's watching TV and
it's a Batman it's a detective annual
with a Brian Bolland cover but like we
didn't go deep into comics in that movie
Mallrats is where I let my comic freak
flag fly so him being in that movie lent
me credibility people like oh [ __ ]
like you know not only does he know Stan
Lee but the Stan Lee's in the movie and
he made a character and stuff and the
movie did not set the world on fire and
do well at all went right in the toilet
but he was on the poster
so people were like oh [ __ ] like
their buddies and [ __ ] like that
gave me credibility that DVD gave me
even more credibility because like they
are [ __ ] friends they hang out he
knows him this guy a hoss over
everything he said so once again he
lifted me up and he was always so
complimentary like he talked about
Mallrats like it was this [ __ ] great
experience and like you know for me and
it was cuz like I was working with him
but I never quite understood like what
was his thing in it but like we learned
later in life he just he was a hammy
to [ __ ] be in movies like and that
was him like getting the [ __ ] be in a
movie and do dialogue you know a prior
to that like on set he was like I've
only done one other camión I said I saw
you in a in a you know Incredible Hulk
and daredevil Incredible Hulk a trial
with Incredible Hulk and he goes I
forgot about that
and he goes I'm talking about and it was
was it the hearse or the [ __ ] the
nurse [ __ ] I forget what it was but it
was like a horror movie that purse could
be one of those things but it was uh it
was like a horror movie he's got a brief
appearance in or something like that and
was if Noah wasn't my hand because
didn't Michael Caine play like a comic
book illustrator who gets his hand
chopped off but that would be amazing if
he wasn't it like Stan the man in the
hand he he did man he gave me lots of
credibility that just I got to spend I
still spend it to this day
I mean [ __ ] and I spend it more now than
I did even back then because I was
talking about this [ __ ] back in like 95
and being like comics and [ __ ] like that
and now we live in that world like you
know that's the beauty of Mallrats and
maybe the only reason why I'm still
[ __ ] like working today or considered
somewhat relevant by some Mallrats
presupposed a world that we come to
exist in now when we made Mallrats
everybody knew who Stan Lee was in that
movie like oh it's [ __ ] Stan Lee and
that wasn't reality but eventually
everybody did know who Stan Lee was we
came into this world evolved into a
world where your mother could pick out
[ __ ] Stan Lee in a movie your
youngest child could pick out Stan Lee
in a movie like he became that [ __ ]
famous he became as famous as we all saw
him as you know as comic book fans and
he got to see that yeah like that's to
me what I think about you know how I
felt when I heard the news like I was
sad because again it's a guy who'd been
in my life for as long as
had a life and and like you said it
always felt as if he would be because it
seemed as if he just was unwilling it to
not be but for a guy to have created
this [ __ ] back in the 60s and 70s to
have had his own dalliance with
Hollywood that went off lead off the
rails to then watch as those things that
he created exploded on the world and
dominate it
you know like who gets that like who
gets to see themselves recognized in a
genius in their own time almost nobody
and for it to be as triumphant as it's
been and for him to be a celebrated as
part of it as he was like nobody gets
that victory lap yeah and he was an
ingredient to like an essential
ingredient so much so that if they make
a movie without a minute people like
what the [ __ ] yeah where was the cameo
you know who do you think you won't
exactly there's certain things we expect
on a stand cameo was one of them yeah he
became a touchstone at that point [ __ ]
okay what else do I got dinner for five
I did Jon Favreau I've been on his show
as a guest he did the Sean IFC years ago
called dinner forefathers great he'd sit
down with four people different people
different walks of life from the
business usually and [ __ ] just eat at
a restaurant and chitchat so one day he
couldn't do it he's getting ready to
[ __ ] be a great director and I was
never that so he called me up and what's
goes he goes hey I need somebody to
[ __ ] take the show over this week and
I thought of you because I know you love
the sound of your own voice and this is
before podcasting he was onto something
and [ __ ] so uh so I said yeah I'd
[ __ ] do that on our feet man [ __ ]
you're gonna open up that door man I'm
[ __ ] Jay Leno this [ __ ] I'll take
your job like okay so he was like you
get to pick your panel I said get out of
here he goes yeah you get to talk to
anybody you want to talk to he's like
that's kind of it like we were just and
who you would talk to itself so try not
to use anybody who ever used before I
was like all right man here's my panel
and so Jason Lee here's that great we've
never had him before let's do him I said
I just finished Jay and Silent Bob
strike back mark Hamill's in it I want
to use Mark Hamill
Luke Skywalker yeah [ __ ] yeah of
course bring him on and then I said you
know who I've talked to the other day
he's real [ __ ] great I told him a
story about you know working on [ __ ]
Superman because he's working on
superman right now a different Superman
is [ __ ] but you know that God does alias
JJ Abrams he's like yeah bring him on
never heard of him bring him on years
ago he goes you got one more who is it I
said Stan Lee he goes Marvel Stan Lee I
said yeah he goes oh that's a great
panel he goes [ __ ] I wish I was doing
the show son no no no it's my panel
locking him down you can see the show
online Stan's wonderful in it and stuff
but it's ironic you know he's sitting
there we're all on Favreau show Favreau
would go on to create the Marvel
Universe right with foggy when he made
Iron Man
built the spine upon which the Marvel
Universe is hung for 10 [ __ ] years
and stuff
JJ of course was sitting across from
Mark Hamill and [ __ ] at one point Mark
Hamill was talking about I always
thought that this is what they should
have done with Luke in the movies if
they kept going this was when there was
no Star Wars in sight this is 2001 right
but JJ's taking notes listening and
going on but Stan was wonderful man like
way you know and he did you know Stan
was wonderful on many levels what was
one of the things was wonderful about
him was his repeat playability so he
reused that Lee joke because Jason Lee
was there is like no relationship what
nearly as good as the Gimli version
though because the Gimli version has the
component yeah agent Johnson Johnson no
all right that was let me see what else
do I got one time I gave him a DVD award
they had this award ceremony and he got
a Lifetime Achievement Award and he
let's see that was nice it was 2000 I
was living out here at this point was
there an MTV life it wasn't it was like
a DVD visionary
or for like you know the DVD I forget
what the name of the organization was
but it was mostly based on home video
and that they were giving him an award
for lifetime achievement creating
characters
I think blade was big at that point so
they were like there's your tie-in and
stuff but he was wonderful and funny and
charming that night when he was at the
not the Pantages but the theater that's
like across the street - yes he was like
when he got up you know I introduced him
and stuff and that when I said give it
up for Stanley [ __ ] place went nuts
and this is years before a Marvel movie
and stuff like that but people knew who
he was I was wearing a Marvel Jersey and
[ __ ] got a picture of that of me and him
I'm standing behind him out of focus
holding his award and he's standing
there at the mic holding [ __ ] court
doing Stan Lee for the crowd and it was
wonderful to [ __ ] see I read on
Twitter today I don't know if it's a
popular sentiment or just somebody wrote
it but I wish I remember the author was
but they said the greatest character
Stanley Lieber ever created was Stan Lee
and it's true Stan Lee was a character
that he created like it was somebody he
put on and then became that guy by the
end of his life there - were
interchangeable but Stan Lee was a tub
thumper you know the a showman a
Salesman dude taught me how to be a
Salesman at the end of the day that's
what Stan did for you know who's creator
but he was a Salesman as well there's
not enough to like I created this comic
book you had to [ __ ] salad he became
an editor at one point so it had to go
beyond simply like I wrote a comic book
you got to sell it and he believed in it
and hockey to have this term sell the
game if you believe in it you sell the
game hey man you gotta come see a hockey
game with me and [ __ ] like that
Stan sold comics like in a big way sold
me on comics for my life and and the
ideals and the values that he instilled
in his work I built my personal and
private life around like I worked by
those codes and I work in the world and
play with the characters and comment on
the characters that he [ __ ] created
and stuff like that
daredevil premiere I remember seeing him
at the daredevil premiere Affleck's
daredevil movie and we all took a
picture together me Ben and [ __ ]
Stanley saw Stan after the movie Stan's
a [ __ ] wonderful gentleman I said
what do you think he goes a lot more
than they did apparently but he liked it
he was he's in it and his cameo in it
and he liked it he liked Mark a lot the
director and stuff
he liked Affleck he thought that he was
like he's wonderful he looks like Matt
Murdock but uh you know before I don't
know if anyone remembers this is true
story they originally went to Matt Damon
to play Matt Murdock and then he passed
and then they went to Ben and Ben was
like [ __ ] yeah and then like those Apple
that's how he wound up yes you like them
apples very much and stuff so he was a
fan man when he was two when a flick was
living at the condo when we were making
chasing amy he he was like I want to
read something give me some exact comic
books every one I gave him Dark Knight
Returns full of loose bows amazing Frank
Miller [ __ ] like that they should do
this is a movie I was like no one's ever
gonna do that as a movie and know what
now you'll never see that version of
Batman ever so later on he was like what
else you got man and I said well you
love [ __ ] Dark Knight Returns you
would love Frank Miller's [ __ ]
daredevil he did daredevil before he did
Batman man so here's the source material
many later on went on to play daredevil
which he referred to it all the time is
[ __ ] Frank that's Frank Miller man
that's Frank Miller I was a guest well
Frank Miller did a run of daredevil I
said but you know he was created by by
huz but that's [ __ ] Frank Miller man
I'm doing them into a Frank Miller
Miller [ __ ] shady shady Stanley is is
kind of my favorite family the one that
drops location the one that drops Loki
[ __ ] shade like there's no tomorrow
there's this amazing clip online that
resurfaced over the last couple of days
it's like you really have minutes long
and it's Stan
hovering over the shoulder of Rob
Liefeld and Todd McFarlane
there at the drawing board I'm like yeah
man we're just gonna I'm gonna make this
character calling overkill and and he's
got this [ __ ] like rocket launchers on
his knees and he's got bandoliers and
everything and sins like you guys don't
think much about this do you
it's like nah man we just like to make
it come up as we go and it's very
free-flowing like you'd be better off if
you thought about it a little bit his
knees to shoot small people I did
literally just every [ __ ] day just
you could see it like bubbling up in him
be oh this guy can't draw a feet at all
Wow
it's it is the most delicious like three
and a half minutes you will watch today
I really is I watched he's used an art
director to like he was he was writer
art director editor-in-chief of Marvel
Comics Alden and I he had a nine you had
a [ __ ] package he's like that no I
watched him throw Loki shade at Johnny
Rotten to his [ __ ] face it was so
strange we had this poetry event my kid
was in school she went to the Hollywood
school house here in town
my dentistry and they had a it was
Poetry Month and they had an idea to do
this like poetry event as a fundraiser
so you know my wife is like we'll do it
at our house and I was like what and we
wound up hosting it there I was like the
emcee and we had a [ __ ] full slate of
guests who's pretty impressive slate of
guests I got up and introduced as a
thank you for coming tonight and giving
up for that most noble and needy of
causes private school children and
and introduced a hosts of guests one of
them was Stanley Stan came twice we had
two poetry events and he came both years
and people [ __ ] loved in both times
but before he came the first year yeah I
said hey man we're doing this poetry man
you work I would love to he's like can I
do the Raven and I was like oh my god
yes we'd all love to see that yes please
oh my god so the day before the poetry
event night before poetry event you know
it's gonna be like 200 people in the
house and [ __ ] like that
everything arranged for the next day I
got to get like [ __ ] Parker's because
we live on a hill and there's nowhere to
put cars and [ __ ]
so all that shit's gonna happen caterer
shows up next day this is the night
before there's me and the wife kids out
of the house with their grandparents
we're boning [ __ ] burning somebody
rings the doorbell
which rings the phone that's the phone
hello
hey this is Stanley I said hey man how
are you and he goes great and I'm like
what what's up and he goes I'm here to
read poetry and I said Oh Stan mind you
I'm naked having this conversation
I said Stan that's tomorrow night he
goes you're kidding
and I said yeah there's like no cars
here and he goes oh my god I'm
embarrassed I thought it was tonight I
said you're embarrassed I'm in the
middle of having sex right now because
I'll see you tomorrow have fun softest
garden takes up
I slipped that no prize under the dole
so weird the one of the weirdest moments
of my adult life if I could go back in
time and tell the young comic book
reader one day Stan Lee he's gonna come
to your house but you can't answer
because your balls deep he came back the
next night put on a hell of a [ __ ]
show man both times he did the Raven
once and then he did he wrote a poem
what was it and God spoke I believe it
was or something like that what was it
and God whoa is that it yes really
[ __ ] beautiful stuff but it was crazy
everyone in the room went nuts for him
man
so one year he's there I think it was
the first year for a second year
might be the second year you know the
guests a bunch of weird but not weird
people but a weird list of disparate
people put together stuff means that at
one point I'm sitting at my patio table
Stan Lee sitting to my left Johnny
Rotten from Sex Pistols who was also
reading poetry that night and scaring
the [ __ ] out of everybody in the really
delicious way man to be fair everybody
was like you know entertaining the crowd
and [ __ ] he got up and did a screaming
read of his song abortion at the [ __ ]
crowd you know for kids oh my god and in
the front row they were like smiling and
laughing because they were like hos and
he was like I'm [ __ ] serious it was a
[ __ ] killer end to the show or like
that happened to everybody so those are
that was the end of the night the
beginning of the night for the show
begins there I'm sitting at the table
there Stan and there's Johnny Rotten and
so Stan is being Stan and he's just
poking fun like she'd like to throw a
low-key shake not in a shitty way but he
was old man so he can get away with
saying stuff and whatnot so he's like
look at you look how you're dressed is
that you come to a poetry event and he's
like what's [ __ ] wrong with this and
he's like you're dressed so funny he's
going this guy look at him in the hockey
jersey he's already the funny dresser
he's gone you you should come in a suit
lock him in a sweater
Johnny Rotten goes do you know who I am
dad and it goes yeah you're the guy
dressed like that he goes I'm rotten he
goes I could have told you that it was
adorable is that they're taking shots
man it was [ __ ] nuts it's like mr.
Rogers if he didn't give a [ __ ] because
that's the thing like I'd known him for
we met him in 95 right so I knew him for
23 years that math correct yes and I
knew him through all that I don't give a
[ __ ] years you know and I'm Sam from
like 73 honor every role he was at that
point it's like I don't I'm in my I'm in
my you know just declining years so I
don't now I'm gonna say everything I
want and he kept saying it for two
decades and said [ __ ] like that
Magic Man let's see what else do I got
man
2006 I did an event with him and Joe
Quesada at UCLA called Marvel then and
now kind of looked at the two errors
Stan had been the editor-in-chief of an
entire era and Joe Quesada was currently
the editor-in-chief of that era of
Marvel Comics he's gone on to be the CEO
oh and stuff but that was this weird
wonderful kind of sold-out event at UCLA
that we shot for the hero initiative I
think you could still buy them through
the hero initiative folks magical night
were you know he he talked he told the
Marvel story yet again all the stories
that I knew very well from the DVD I had
done with him like ten years before or
less than ten years before but each one
elegantly [ __ ] told and he held the
crowd wrapped he loved to be a jokester
like you know he's honestly kind of
tired of telling [ __ ] stories about
the characters all the time so he just
liked to heckle the audience and people
had to take excel like hahaha made fun
of me you know
it was kind of magical next up I've got
a fat man on Batman in my house holy
[ __ ] he came over to my place one day to
record fat man I'm Batman
sat down did a great episode max brought
him as his guy at the time his body man
so we got a lot of stairs in my house
you've seen you know I'm walking down
with Stan making sure that he [ __ ]
covers all the way down you know just
like and he's chatting the whole [ __ ]
time so chatty and I'm like let's chat
when we get down these stairs like let's
not talk and move at the same time see
you for once we're not doing it again
no [ __ ] so get them safely down to like
the first floor landing and then there's
like one step and then nine steps down
to the door and those nine steps down to
the door are hard ceramic concrete like
it's not pleasant if you have fallen so
we get him down to the platform and
stuff like that he only has the one
platform and then the stairs and least
home-free so I'm like I I'm gonna stand
here I'm not gonna I've already come
down three flights with him I don't want
to embarrass him by walking him to the
door and stuff like this is enough give
him his dignity and his pride and stuff
he's walking to the door so you know I
said all right man good seeing you stand
and he's walking forward and he turns he
goes you too keV and instantly [ __ ]
goes off the step and then trips on to
the next landing and then goes off that
which all I see in slow-mo is like every
headline go and Kevin Smith kills comic
book legend Stan Lee in murder house and
it's all happened in slow and he is
going man he's twisted and about to fall
face [ __ ] first in a big bad way max
his body man comes out of nowhere
catches him just [ __ ] catches him
before hits ground lifts him right back
to his feet as if he's done this a
thousand times
and I go Jesus Stan he goes I'm good max
got me goodbye out they [ __ ] went man
scary scary [ __ ] just a Tuesday
withstanding pretty much we did a
commercial together right around the
time of a Voltron when it came out with
Audi wanted to do a spot the Stanley
school of cameo acting you could find it
online it's adorable little spot where
you know it's like Stanley the master of
cameo acting and he's conducting a class
and in the class is Jason Mewes and may
Michael Rooker and Tara Reid one of
these things is not like the other two
Funspot men and lou ferrigno comes in at
one point like he comes to the room he's
I guess that's the anger management
class and stands like no son that's down
the hallway and he backs out of the room
going what it said and then stand at the
end of it like he's teaching everybody
how to be a cameo acting so he puts on
like a hat and it's like generals hat
he's like this is cameo acting then he
puts on Thor's helmet he's like this is
real acting really adorable spot and
whatnot had a blast shooting it with
them but they had this very special
moment at the end of the shoot it's been
all day with them chit-chatting with
them you know at this point like age of
Ultron was how many years ago eight no
probably more like three eight no it
can't be age I mean Black Panther was
February and so I have no sense of time
it's true sounds like a thousand years
somebody look it up what is it three
years ago three years ago 2015 20
[ __ ] 15 that seems like a lifetime
ago mass it seems like an infinity war
ago
Wow [ __ ] okay so this is three years
ago so you know I've known him for a
long [ __ ] time at this point I put in
a bunch of time at this point two
decades we've known each other so he had
a blast that he asked for me
specifically to come direct and stuff
like that they came to him the ad agency
with the Audi spa and he was just like
why don't you get Kevin Smith for years
he'd always been like you gotta cast me
in something else and I was like I cast
you in a movie and it died no and then
later on when he started making the
Marvel movies like you see my box office
grosses record it's bigger he goes it's
bigger than Will Smith's now he's gone
cuz I'm in all these Marvel movies going
to you look at the chart it goes like
this and then it goes down to Mallrats
you ruined my record keV the all right
so wait where was I in that story howdy
so we do this spot chit chat with him
all day long and stuff we all take
pictures that's what I'm trying to do
Mallrats too and we all take the picture
holding up with two fingers and stuff
there's me Stan J and Michael Rooker all
four of us were in mall rats and stuff
so at the end of the day I'm talking to
his person and we did our last shot Stan
was done we sent him off but we were
doing a shot of Lou Ferrigno walking
down the road and then the car drives
past it and so I'm sitting there
chit-chatting is his man came to watch
the show and watch us finish shooting
and he was like I love watching this
stuff this is fun as always said your
man did great Stan was wonderful
all day long he kept his energy up man
he was funny like is I can't believe
this guy he's 92 at that point or
something like that and I was like he's
still raring to go and his guy goes you
know he loves you and I was a guy I love
him too and he goes no he loves you he
thinks be like a [ __ ] son
that one that one was that was a big
moment I went home and I cried to my
wife man I was like I never knew that
that would feel I didn't know that was
missing in my life to hear that I heard
that and I was like oh my god I [ __ ]
melted next time I saw him I gave him a
big hug
what else so I got he goes I did this
interview with him and his wife well
mostly it was him for legion em you know
legion em group they were responsible
for him getting his hands put in the and
his footprints at the Chinese Theatre
last year right around this time if I
remember correctly so legion em put
together this shoot that they asked me
to come interview Stan the idea was we
did this VR virtual reality interview
where they shot with these cameras that
shoot it's insane [ __ ] resolution we
they couldn't do playback because they
didn't have a monitor to playback the
technology they were shooting ONC's that
it was too far advanced like they were
on 10 or 12 [ __ ] K and they're like
we don't have a monitor to play it back
so we will in two years but they're like
we want to shoot this now because you
know Stan's getting old and so we're
gonna make sure that we captured it so
we did this sit-down interview and it's
in like the room at his house that's got
some great artwork in it and great
Marvel pieces and you know it's kind of
like an update a 20 year later version
of Marvel's mutants and monsters but
it's all fixated on Stan's long life and
career and not just in comics before he
got into comics and everything and at
one point
Johnny joins us his wife this is you
know a couple months before she passed
on and she sits down for an interview
little bonus piece that we're gonna do
two things I remember insanely clearly
one as she sat there doing the interview
Stan sat right off camera in the corner
the room and he had love on his face man
like he [ __ ] love that woman sat
there listening to her interview it had
this big [ __ ] smile on his face love
in his eyes it was goofy it's wonderful
I remember that very very clearly and
then I remember this moment doing the
interview with Joanie and setting her up
to tell the story once again about how
you know she told Stan to let go for it
just write what you want if you're gonna
leave that company write what you want
for a change and he did and it was the
Fantastic Four and it started all this
[ __ ] began big bang that started the
Marvel Universe so she's about to tell
the story and Joanie gets emotional her
eyes tear up and I said you okay
and she goes it's always spider-man
spider-man spider-man they don't know
that the man is a poet and Stan is
sitting right over in the corner of the
room and he gets misty and she starts
talking about his writing that he does
that nobody ever sees she's like you'll
never no one will ever see the beautiful
things that he's written she knew a
different version of the guy like we all
appreciate you know [ __ ] what he did
for us but they were in a long long
marriage and they still dug each other
right up to the end when she passed away
like a week later is when we did the
Chinese Theater ceremony with the
footprints and there was a question as
to whether or not he would be up for it
at that point but he showed up and he
put on Stanley for everybody else you
know like I'm sure there's a personal
piece of like oh right on I'm gonna be
immortalized and Grauman's but like he'd
been immortalized a thousand times over
you know I was just one more thing one
more feather for the cap and I'm sure it
would have been much more preferable to
sit home and just think about his great
great loss but instead
put on the [ __ ] sweater and he put on
that character and stanley lieber who
was brokenhearted at the death of his
wife Joanie
put on Stanley for the rest of us went
out and was there for that ceremony Mann
was a true professional and was always
thinking about me and you and you and
everybody in this [ __ ] room or
anybody who could potentially pick up a
comic book or any kid who could be
affected by some magical story some
simple parable about somebody making the
right choice as opposed to the wrong
choice guy was a class act all the way
let's see what else do I got he was in
yoga hosers but that's best left unsaid
you know what [ __ ] it I am gonna say
here's there's a cute story there's a
clip I got that a Christian the composer
on the show he did tusky did yo Gosar's
as well
he sent me yesterday after Stan passed
and it's a clip of me directing Stan on
yoga hosers
and it's me going you know explaining
what a hoser is and blah blah blah but
it's come after the first take and his
first take is pitch perfect if you've
ever seen the movies like the dispatch
officer the girls call when all hell is
breaking loose at the convenience store
and when they you know that they tell
them some incredible [ __ ] about [ __ ]
Nazi sausages and [ __ ] and then the line
goes dead and he looks at the phone and
he says goddamn yoga hosers you know and
that's it first take and stuff you do
that [ __ ] gets to that moment line goes
dead and he goes
god damn yoga horses
and everybody on camera like I'm behind
the monitor I see the image shake cuz
everyone's laughing on camera and [ __ ]
like that
so I go out there and I'm like it was
beautiful but it's yoga hosers and he
goes yoga hosers
what the hell was that that's like let
me walk it there and I explained what it
is he goes Yoga hosers Yoga hosers ok I
think I got it let's go
Yoga hosers it's your movie yoga pose my
movies have made 17 billion dollars yeah
and yoga hoses I did a pilot for AMC a
couple years ago Steve Agee Agee was on
with me as well he tweeted about orders
in the comment section of my Instagram
reminded me it was called screenplay and
the idea was you did scenes from movies
and stuff it's kind of fun they didn't
mind of going with it they did pickup
geeking out which I joined so we shot
the pilot and the at the end it was kind
of like a quasi gameshow whoever won won
the Stanley Cup and Stanley came out and
presented a cup you know so we brought
him out to do it any time he called him
he came out didn't matter what it was
for like he did I think twice he was on
comic book men came down sat with us at
the table went on another time he was
just hanging out with the boys in the
show one of my favorite episodes of the
show and one of my favorite images as
well Stanley sitting on the counter at
the secret stash and four grown men
laying on the floor at his feet like
children as he tells them stories and
stuff it's how we all felt when we were
around the guy man he was a great
storyteller and a legend what else I got
man
I am dB two summers ago I interviewed
him it's cute clip you could find it
online I interviewed him at San Diego
Comic Con the IMDB boat and I told them
that he had a role in Jay and Silent Bob
reboot so I was like well let's
audition you right now and so we wind up
doing this little bit where I give him a
line of dialogue to do and he can't
[ __ ] do it without cracking up and
it's adorable it's a genuine laugh he's
making himself laugh and stuff it's a
really cute clip he can find it on IMDB
I did an auction with him from Florida
Kahn we raised much money together I was
on stage with him that seemed like a
minute ago in 2016 the New York Comic
Con he did interviews with Stan and Walt
Simonson and Chris Claremont was a
Marvel Legends panel and stuff and he
was holding court and in a great way his
vision was starting to go and his
hearing was getting harder and stuff but
he was still in total stand mode up on
stage you know give him that mic and
he's off and running then the Chinese
Theater foot print ceremony which is
like like I said a week after maybe two
weeks I think it was only a week after
Joanie passed and he still got up and
gave the best Stanley possible had
people get up give him tributes and
stuff I got to be the emcee that was
really sweet
and whatnot and I got to see him put his
hands and feet print like I don't live
far from that place I live up in the
hills and when I was a kid I came out to
Hollywood like when I was like 7 no 9
with my family and I was big into this
[ __ ] love movies and whatnot so you know
I was like we gotta go to the Chinese
Theater because the r2d2 and c3po and
Darth Vader they put their feet in the
in the cement and so I got a picture of
me and my brother sitting in front of
those footprints and [ __ ] like that now
I got somebody for real to go visit man
you know what I'm saying like I know a
guy I knew a guy whose prints are there
and it's kind of comforting now to know
that like you just stroll down there and
if I can hang out and and look at like
he's a piece of the town forever last
time I saw Stan face to face was on his
birthday last year max his body man
called me up and said we're having a
95th birthday party surprise party for
Stannis you sure that's a good [ __ ]
idea the word surprise 95 these things
don't go together
soft surprise yeah he said we won't yell
loud hey so we went to steakhouse in
Beverly Hills and there with bunch of
people Lou Ferrigno was there as well
and Stan came in and we all softly said
happy birthday and he was like I
remember his first reaction goes who are
these people I think came in and got his
propers and sat down at the table and
stuff and I went over and chit chatted
with him for a bit took pictures every
time every time he ever saw me after say
hey keV one of the first things he would
say is when we making another movie
again always and he asked me that day
and I said real [ __ ] soon man I
promise you like we're so close
they sell fantastic and we took picture
and and then I didn't see him again then
you know a couple months later I had a
heart attack and last few months had
been kind of about that and I got a I
got a request on Friday Jordan you know
who runs our company Jason's wife she
goes Stan wants to see you and I said
what she goes they asked if you'd come
up and see Stan and I've been you know
it was a weird year with Stan like a
certain point I didn't have his number
couldn't reach out to him tried put up a
tweet about like you could come live
with me and [ __ ] like that like so you
know it was a year fraught with peril
for him last year of his life was you
know spent dodging stories and stuff
like that so for a while I couldn't see
him couldn't contact him and then all of
a sudden
here I was being you know said he wants
to see you so I said of course when
they're like as soon as possible they're
like he's good for like five seven
minutes but he's asking about you and so
I was like all right ma'am like I'm home
all next week
lock it in so I supposed to go see him
this week and then I was walking the dog
the other day and that's just got a call
from Jordan and I said what's up and she
goes
the reporters announcing that Stan just
passed that was a tough [ __ ] morning
like he was a great man and you know
he's [ __ ] 95 and clothes closing in
on 96 so he had a legendary life but
like it's just weird being in a world
where like those stories stop that's it
so I had to write [ __ ] down so I didn't
forget you take for granted the time
that you have with people and then one
day you realize [ __ ] you don't get to
make anymore memories amazing things I
got to make any memories at all can't
believe I met the man once let alone
could call him friend that beautiful
dude gave me a [ __ ] ring could have
got married to him I mean today like a
couple years back knots of mine might
have been tough but you know we could
have made it work he he told weirder
stories you know inside it says to Kevin
from Stanley it's got my fat man logo
it's really sweet he gave it to me twice
because he forgot he gave it to me the
first time
I have two rings wonderful [ __ ] man
first time I was given that ring was not
by Stanley himself it was a con that I
went to in Atlantic City in New Jersey
and they said Stan wants you to go to
this Condon interview him oh okay all
right
Atlantic City fine and when I got there
that like Stan didn't make it and I was
like who am i interviewing they go a
Stanley puppet and I got to tell you the
puppet looked really good bad I was like
oh [ __ ] they pulled it off and he gave
me that ring cuz it was from Stan
himself the next time I saw standing
gave me another copy and I was like oh
my god thank you I didn't want to tell
him like your puppet gave me one I'm
already married to your puppet is nuts
though man what a special relationship
now cherish it forever and I will miss
him all my days this is dude responsible
for a lot of what I do a lot of what I
talk about a lot of what I believed and
proselytized for years and stood behind
it was like this [ __ ] matters it's not
just [ __ ] disposable junk culture
like it can make you feel make you sore
can make you want to be something better
like this shit's important and because
of that like I wound up in that dude's
life for a while man it's really [ __ ]
special it's weird
that it's over I guess it makes sense
all things come to a close and you know
death makes life that much more precious
and [ __ ] did he have a great run you
know but still it sucks still I miss it
and still it seems [ __ ] unfair seem
close to living forever didn't he you
know like he was just always there like
an everliving paternal got damn close
and now he is is a turtle named written
and the Stars and stuff like they'll
never be forgotten
kidding me they won't remember me they
won't remember a lot of [ __ ] but they'll
remember him in like a hundred
two hundred three hundred [ __ ] years
we don't know who wrote the Greek myths
but we know who wrote our new mythology
names attached to it forever man give it
up for the one and only the sensational
Stan Lee
[Applause]
alright enough about us let's open it up
to other people men other people got to
have some [ __ ] stand stories I can't
be the only one and stuff so JC
find us some eulogize er some more don't
kill us
uh-oh we got a taker man right up front
JC's working on some [ __ ] he's now gonna
give you the mic Oh give me that mic yet
now you're good what's your name young
camper hi my name is Ryan Ryan
give it up for Ryan thank you what do
you got for us true believer well
here--here's the thing man you tell us a
good stance to her you're gonna walk
away with a prize not just like feeling
good about sharing getting some [ __ ] off
your chest and whatnot but we're gonna
give you some tickets our good friend
deacon and the good folks at 4dx are
always giving us tickets that we like to
give out here if you've never seen a
movie in 40x
oh my god you haven't [ __ ] lived it
is fantastic you can go see the Grinch
right now as directed by SModcast Sohn
Scott [ __ ] Mosers and then we'll we
this weekend made [ __ ] more money in
one weekend than all of our movies
together put together like fantastic so
you can go check out the Grinch and a 40
X theater you can check out anything you
want so if you tell a good enough Stan
story you're gonna get that and we're
also gonna give you a signed print from
our very own Dark Knight Returns Nate
Gonzales man this is a fat man on Batman
print
Batman Beyond sorry fat man beyond print
I always forget I'm signed by mark and I
think me I will have to sign that man
you will have to sign okay then then
you'll get one of those and if you don't
get one you could buy one on your way
out Nate's elemen so you'll get one of
those and what's this oh my god you're
getting prizes galore man Wow what is it
Wow oh that's beautiful oh this is from
the thing after party to follow Stark
mansion what the [ __ ] I was invited to
an after party this is a legion em put
this together what a gorgeous poster
celebrating Stan's imprint sir no what
were you at the stank party join with
fans imprint ceremony celebrate are here
is that one we did it was in July of
this year 2017 [ __ ]
Wow yes cuz wait
Black Panther hadn't come out yet but
Chadwick Boseman was there but he had
played Black Panther because I referred
to him was just like his lordship or
something
Wow [ __ ] now thank you for placing it
for me
2017 okay so you're gonna get how many
posters we got three all right so wow
you're getting the package man you can
get tickets you're gonna get a fat man
beyond print by an eight and you're
gonna get one of these Legion M Stan
posters you better have a [ __ ] story
no I do all right hit us hit us my very
first convention it was in WonderCon in
2005 and I got to ask you a question you
told a story about writing Superman on a
plane and then you fax a blank pages so
shortly after that my very first I go
Comic Con was in 2005 and I got to ask
Stanley two questions and the first one
was about his monologue and Marv bats
and he said I asked if it was true and
he said you see it motion pictures they
have what you call a script and boy did
Joni my wife give me a hard time like
who is this woman who is this girl that
you couldn't get over and who is she
she was really mad and he told her oh
you see in motion pictures they have
what you call a script as he tell me
well it wasn't true because no girl
would ever turn me down and my other
question was about how he felt about the
changes they made into movies and he
said it's all about the spirit you know
it would been corny if you know the
x-men costumes were colorful it would be
the korneyev Hulk was like Hulk smash
and you know with spider-man he made him
he hasn't been by radioactive spider but
to update it they haven't been by a
genetic the altered spiders so he
approved the changes as long as it
pertained to the spirit of his works so
that's my Stan Lee story it's a great
Stan Lee story give it up for up here
gonna walk away or some [ __ ] take this
take this and take this all you well
done who's next man fix us up JC JC once
again for those watching at home the
proprietor of this here fine
establishment scum and villainy cantina
what's your name young camper Leon Leon
everyone give it up for Leon you don't
relate to that many Leon's anymore man
it's good for you it's not many of us
know who the king of Leon's I wish
could've cut the [ __ ] of cashton and
likewise Leon's are like white tigers
yeah especially short ones thank you
I had the chance so growing up you know
reading comic books like everyone here
one of the first books that I read that
ever got me really interested in comics
was how to draw comics the Marvel way oh
what a great book such an amazing book
can you draw I can't draw so that's my
story so when I met I was at New York
City Comic Con and met Stanley to get an
autograph and said you know one of the
things that got me excited about writing
in doing stuff was how to draw comics
the Marvel way because that's great and
he goes this time I think is
you know that's an artbook right that's
about drawing and I was like yeah I
can't draw any goes there's a lot of
competition I should introduce you to
and that was my moment of meeting
Stanley and having him try to pawn me
off to DC or somebody else at that time
awesome Jerry bad give it up for them
that's great [ __ ] Stan story Oh who's
next
who wants a chance to win some booty
what's your name how's it going my name
is Greg Greg right everyone give it up
for Greg maybe you and Leon should see
about switching names I'm just saying
it's also good to see you again mark
absolutely yeah I was actually I had a
really good time with Stan one time it
was over at New York comic-con it was a
while back it was one of many times that
was said is the last time you go see
Stanley or anything like that a free pop
promotes promoted him like that heavily
I was going through a thing where I'm a
software engineer but I was like trying
to write for a while nothing took off
and you know like I was still in a stage
where I was I kind of like shaken
whatever you talk to a celebrity like
hey Stanley like I was wondering like
where do you know 23 years I was still
that way yeah he called me shakey Bob I
will say this you always remembered my
name
Jason Mewes not so much so it always
feel like hey keV hey you
be like Jase if you like that's right
Jason and then Jason directing a movie
called method madness and the method and
Stan did a cameo for him and Jason cried
on set the day that he directed Stan Lee
like it's sincere crying because he was
just like I I never imagined that like I
would do anything with Stan Lee I was
like you weren't a [ __ ] movie with a
man and he goes yeah that was your movie
this is my movie really beautiful back
to you but yeah I was asking him
basically about something I was writing
at the time I won't do a Stan Lee
impression I'm sort of terrible at it
and I own it
rocket ride I I was like oh what exactly
do you find it hits the core of all
these characters and make him last so
long and everything like that he takes a
moment he's like hope hope is the main
thread that I have through everything
all these characters are looking towards
the future and like like just took me I
move in I took a step back and I was
like yeah and so I like walking around a
convention I'm just thinking about that
like hope like hope is where I'm missing
and that chunk of my story and
everything like that so I'm like still
thinking about and I'm walking past a
booth and like someone says something to
him he's like oh look hope is the main
threat I'm like okay so I got I learned
three things from that incident one Stan
Lee worse like you've already
established he repeats a lot of things
oh yeah but it's the thought that he was
also such a heavily like a marketer and
he was doing it to the point where he
actually like studied before meetings or
it would be like a book that he wasn't
even riding on he's like what it like
was a moon night and so he was like go
ahead and like research everything and
then set it on a course for where any
eight to go second thing was because of
that I was just like I wanna like he was
like already he was about 92 at that
time and I was just like I just want to
be there I want I want to be with that
same energy
and with that same level of like work
aptitude that he's working on that level
and much like you like within the past
month I'm like I want to go vegan I
wanna I won't live forever with that
same kind of energy and like so that was
huge and the third thing was yeah he was
right like um like mark knows was I
ended up writing on like American Gods
and like I'm doing like just more stuff
now but the one thing I have with
everything is just that like I know
there's a wrong POC has to say this on
where it's like I'm more of a Superman
guide and a Batman guy get the [ __ ] out
your Stan Lee story where where Batman
is on top of a building and he looks
down at Gotham Superman is on a building
almost parallel and metropolis and he
looks up and a lot of the characters
that he created when while he was making
them they looked up they looked at the
future they looked at hope and they they
represent that they end like that same
level and I think I don't know as
creators we like we can carry on that
legacy of just hope it's true cuz that's
we all as something we can all identify
with to can't identify with getting
bitten by a radioactive spider I don't
even think I've ever been written by a
non radioactive spider and [ __ ] so we
can't identify with like the big strokes
that make the characters so memorable
but what you can identify with is like
you know something like that like hey
man I like those characters I hope I
have hope I have that like you know the
idealism of a young Peter Parker is
something some of us still carry later
on in life you know at age [ __ ] 48 and
stuff clearly past midlife and stuff but
still hope you know kind of keeps it
going it's excellent point it's great
story give him some [ __ ] tickets bad
he won
[Applause]
another poster pleasure JC what he got
for us man hey what's your name I'm Sean
Sean everyone give it up for Sean Sean
tell us a Stanley's story so I'm from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
ah and unfortunately missed you during
Dogma I kicked myself for later of
course I kicked myself for Dogma all the
time when I was almost gonna die I was
like I'm going to help as a Dogma so you
know like most of us here I made my
journey across the country as we made
journeys here tonight to talk about Stan
and to chase those parts of ourselves
that we've kind of hope existed so I
kept missing Stan throughout the years
and I finally made it to a con that that
Stan would be at last year's Silicon
Valley Comic Con I have two children and
and they both have autism and so I tried
taking them to a previous con and they
kind of never weren't able to connect to
my life you know the problems they would
face and so this year whenever stan was
announced I was like you know I'd love
to take him but I just can't you know
and at the last minute a friend was able
to come through and bring them in just
for a photo shoot we have with them you
know and my youngest is four and he's
you know dressing as a Hulk outfit and
he speaks no words and so we came in you
know take a picture with him and I knelt
down to him I said hey say hi nope it's
just a guy and he's think you know I
gave it a few shots to do not trying to
take your time and and and I heard hi
Hulk and I hope beyond hope that it was
my son that was like wait a minute who
said that and I turned around and it was
Stan notice at the time where he wasn't
really saying much during that call like
everyone was talking about it and like
it felt the same as if my son had said
it you know because it was like that
sink
and uh yeah it was a really great won't
have a moment [ __ ] beautiful give it
up it's a fantastic story of course you
get [ __ ] tickets course you get a
poster that [ __ ] rocked well done man
that's what we're talking about
everybody got a Stan Lee story man even
the people don't meet him best Stanley
story what do you got for us what's your
name
Damien yeah well give it up for Damien
hey so I've been I've been very lucky to
have met and worked with Stan several
times through my through my short trip
around this world compared to him I seen
him in many conventions and and God how
many TV shows movies that he's been and
moved out to Hollywood because I wanted
to work in movies and you know make the
superhero films and everybody else is
not making and got a job first I came
out here during Hurricane Katrina and
literally driving through the wreckage
and the horror of all that I get a job
at CAA talent agency here in town and
first week I'm there I get a call from
somebody upstairs in the offices and the
partners they go get that Damien kid up
to the big conference room and I'm like
what the hell did I do and they're like
Stanley's coming and we need you to
entertain them and I was like what
you're like Hollywood is good like
you've got no other nerds in the
building and so I get up there and I'm
like how long do I have to no longer
have to talk to him for and they go
about 30 minutes the boss is late how am
I gonna talk to Stanley oh I know comics
and I was like but he'd probably always
hears about that so I went in and just
how you doing I'm Damien I'm love comics
I love what you've done
tell me you know let's let's talk about
life and he asked me where I been where
I've come from what I'm doing and
everything and Gil his partner at the
time was like oh Jesus not another one
these geeks and so so Stan you know he
gets my life story and we talked a
little bit and
and you know 30 minutes go by and he
goes you know Damien he goes take away
from this what you will he goes he goes
and I'm glad you read my stuff and I
know he goes but just be a good person
and he goes that if you want it go for
it he goes otherwise it's never gonna
happen
he goes you have to go for it and I was
like all right that's that's amazing and
I said thank you so much he goes there's
a pleasure to pleasure to have you so
the next day I'm sent to Robert Downey
jr. 'he's trailer filming iron man to
drop off a statue that i happen to get
just because I was a I just happen to
know somebody at Sideshow Collectibles
how do I get your [ __ ] job man I'm
like I would do that job I'd be that
perfect you get to meet Robert Downey
jr. what the again it's it's putting
myself where I needed to be and and
being good to people and following what
he said and from the takeaway was just
be a good person be you be yourself and
get out there and good things will
happen and then you know next thing I
know I'm in Jersey going through your
warehouses selling your stuff for
auction oh you were awesome man proper I
did prop works and and you know it got
to work with Wizard World and then next
thing I know I'm directing Stan on
camera and doing all the stuff with all
the celebrities and and whatnot and then
the next thing I know I'm working with
Legion em and we're putting together the
handprints ceremony for Stan Lee and
it's just one each day we put it
together so you're responsible for Stan
getting his [ __ ] hands and the food
goddamn I give it up for Damon Oh for
you Damon
but it's but again and it's it's just
crazy just it's it's what Stan said it's
be a good person treat that's what it
might take away from him and his life is
it's learn to be the best person you can
there's no reason a step on anybody else
emulate the heroes who you love be the
person that you know you can be live
your life have fun enjoy it and good
things will happen
crappy things happen too but you take
him good and bad Stan had a world of
crap things happen but he always took
the best
it and he always made it better and
that's what I've always learned from
from all the fun things and being able
to them and when we're sitting in the
office of the TCL I was looking around
I'm seeing pictures of all these
celebrities around the world and I was
like my celebrity's not here my hero why
isn't our hands in there and they're
like oh my god they are it I was like I
can make a few calls
you [ __ ] did the Lord's work in doing
that man but it wasn't about me it was
about him and that's thank you I
appreciate you guys you know I
appreciate everybody doing the hands but
it's not about me it's about a caring
that experience it was thanking him for
all the love that he gave to us which is
amazing but again like you you were you
made it happen
like other with the help of other people
yes I'm not really but somebody just
happen to get it somebody had the good
idea long story short be good people
love everyone around you do kind things
and emulate the heroes that this man
wrote and that's the best thing what we
can do
fuckin'-a man Damien definitely wins man
Danny take tickets take a closer no
you're good so what you do one more [ __ ]
you want without playing give it up she
won what's your name young camber I
don't think we have [ __ ] to give away
but I'm probably not gonna get anything
because unfortunately I'll probably be
the first son Stanley story of the night
okay in fact you are my Stanley as
you've been saying through the night the
only I I grew up I was born in 89 sorry
James my friends call me Chuck everyone
give it up for what chunk Chuck Chuck
wait you're James but they call you
chuck you can't choose your nicknames
very true give it up for Chuck what did
you do Chuck to get to be a Chuck when I
forward I used to cut the Chuck Liddell
hair cut in and I come back after the
weekends and everyone's like what's that
for Chuck Liddell was my favorite
fighter Chuck stuck Chuck stuck so I'm
fixed you've been saying through the
night like I grew up in 89 so I grew up
in the era of animation
not comic books I wasn't ADHD sorry I'm
more like butterflies than sit still and
read as much as pictures or cartoons
yeah yeah x-men cartoon I grew up with
spider-man grew up with all that but the
first time I was introduced to Stanley
was Mallrats
I didn't understand who created this is
I used to jump on my trampoline for
three hours pretending to be the spot
named sweeping flip you know but the
first time I realized who made all that
was due to you and I know if you could
talk by the jump I'm wearing but six
months ago you I don't know if anyone
knows but Kevin Smith had a heart attack
and I don't [ __ ] tell peri Khalid is
trying not to tell you but because of
that like I'd caught I'd written into
Hollywood babble-on like big fan and and
he was like I'll maybe next year but
then you had the heart attack and I'm
like I'm waiting for that sorry I did it
clerk so I sold half my staff hit up
everyone who open Me 2 cents so didn't
an extra 12 hours a week and I've come
from Brisbane Australia to be here and
as much as Stanley as an awesome man I
feel like he stole the Thunder and I'm a
bit of a dick to be doing this now and
I'm not going to be getting anything to
win but I've had a question you a movie
used to last 90 minutes for me you know
beginning to end done I'd go on with my
day and then I watched Jay and Silent
Bob and they became my favorite movie of
all time
within a month or two I knew it word for
word beginning to end I could do half
the youth measurements and like accents
and impersonations and then a year and
half later my friend was like I told him
how much I loved it he was like oh I
know clerks my favorite I'm like what's
clerks and then that started as far as I
was aware you were the first person to
create a movie universe I learned
previously and after that that year was
like the monster movie universe and
stuff and so forth but I'd always I'd
always wondered was that something you'd
done by purpose and in the sense of
winning things I tailored it to mark in
the same sense of the question I was
going to ask was one was it always
because before that it was like sequels
and prequels it was like a one story arc
but then I was shown aside Bob and then
I watched clerks and half an hour into
it he's transformed Bob so it's it's a
story outside a main arc I would always
wondered was that your main purpose to
great
like once you done collects really like
I'm gonna keep going not following my
story like I said ten years later clerks
to where it was but it was like you know
those fellas were hanging outside the
store do you ever wonder what happened
to them
that's what otherwise sort of outside of
the movie you made movies last longer
than the 90 minutes they ran for me
you're the reason I'm a cinephile
dirtier than I yes filthy I got a little
hard when you said it was like yeah
let's signify all yeah sorry I'm not
gonna win nothing but I still marc has
had one thing to say all night because
he met him once
exactly all right so just so I'd like to
ask question if you had to put and I was
happy enough to meet Jay and he answered
the same question but it was if you had
to put side Bob into any other universe
other than the view askew naver's who
would you put it in and why and Mark we
live in the reality and he obviously as
far as I'm aware don't have a movie
character so if you had to put yourself
into any other movie universe why Silent
Bob I put him into the universe of a
quiet place easy costume he'd be in
every sequel he is an expert at not
being detected he's very quiet I've
thought about this a lot yeah I'm just
waiting for John Krasinski to give me
the coffee I'll be right there
I don't think I've ever heard the
questions that you've been waiting for
have y'all I have been I was the John
Hughes universe I don't know why but I
could see you sitting on the corner did
you see which way she went trying to
catch it before she got on a plane it
has yeah but but let's be honest that
quiet play that made a lot of that's all
you so that's your bread and butter yes
that would be mine what about you I got
to put myself in any movie universe yeah
shaft well that's one I mean one which
one old Shafter the remakes
it's all the same universe right does
any [ __ ] shop do maybe chef goes to
Africa I don't know it sounds like the
travelogue is in it to win it but yeah I
would like to be a sex machine with all
the chicks
that's it happen often yes I will take
the opportunity thank you both so much
and but wait let me go back to your
other question because it is it comes
back to Stan in some way the reason that
I connected all the movies is because of
comics because of Stan because you know
in New York like Ironman new spider-man
and [ __ ] they knew the Avengers and
they knew the Fantastic Four it was all
connected so you know I definitely owe a
bit to John Hughes of course all of his
movies were also connected they didn't
crossover but they were all most of them
took place in sheer Illinois's so it was
the eye and also our John Landis
deserves a little credit particularly
for the cinematic inspiration of it
because I remember going to see coming
to America and at one point like hakeem
winds up giving money to Mortimer and
and off and Randolph the two dudes who
are in trading places with [ __ ] Eddie
Murphy and I remember sitting the
audience be like holy [ __ ] they're
connected that's how I felt with J
that's why somebody gave it to me so I
passed it on my movies but building the
universe I took straight from comics so
I've seen a lot of people over the years
ago Kevin Smith did [ __ ] Cinematic
Universe before Marvel but Kevin Smith
stole her from Marvel in the first place
so technically they did it first vicious
circle yes on that night not also
because I don't have a fight with
Stanley and now never will have the
opportunity take a picture after the
shift I know laying out on someone with
you I would be more than happy we've got
an ally just for leaning I am not worthy
I am no one excellent question give it
up for a man is fantastic we have we got
no prizes but will you definitely take
one more man I will keep it Kip quick
sorry oh yeah thank you it's Tom DeSanto
and Tom hold on hold on for those that
don't [ __ ] know Tom responsible for
giving you the comic-book movies man
that the before you had [ __ ] Marvel
movies you had Marvel movies you had Tom
is responsible for the x-men movies give
it up for one of the greatest comic book
movies ever [ __ ] made still to this
day is x2 so yes and you know thank you
for having this here tonight because I
think all of us were feeling a little
bit alone and missing Stan agreed gave
us a little bit of community here and
you know look around and into the eyes
of the person next to you and Stan lives
in that person because he made each of
us a better soul and that was something
that I felt as a recovering Catholic as
well from New Jersey we're in a very
small fraternity is a very unfortunately
large fraternity yet the first time I
met Stan was July of 96 where I got to
pitch x-men one to him that'll be a
whole another story but I want to tell a
story of Stan Lee's first cameo which
was in x-men 1 what was that was he on
the beach now where is he was on the
beach yes so we were and this was when
Marvel and Stan were sort of at odds so
we were those that not to talk to
Stanley for those that don't remember
historical context there was a moment
where Stan wound up suing marvelous long
before Marvel was owned by Disney and
whatnot it was compared by most people
to Colonel Sanders sue in Kentucky Fried
Chicken it definitely was and my heart
was always with the colonel so we were
trying to convince Stan to come up to
Toronto because we were shooting x-men
were there and he was being kind of
resistant I think because of the bad
blood that was going on and I was
talking with John over in his office and
I got stand on the phone and Stan goes
Tom I can't go up to Canada I'm like San
why can't you come up he's like because
I don't know if will let me back
in the country and I said I think you're
just making excuses because of the
lawsuit and he's like yeah he's like
Marvel doesn't want me there and I said
Stan you are Marvel you need to be in
this movie so we couldn't convince him
to go to Canada but we had two days
shooting over in Paradise Cove over in
Malibu where Senator Kelly comes out and
we convince Dan to come out for his
cameo so it is again it is like Jesus
coming to sad and everyone is there to
see Stanley and he looks at the script
and he goes you know I come all the way
out here and you guys can't write me one
line and I said Stan there's no lines in
the script he's like alright I'll do it
but it's the last one I'm doing without
a line mm-hmm so Stan did his cameo and
we finished up the day and he was
gracious enough to sit back and take
pictures with every extra that came up
every person so to wrap it up that was
the type of guy Stan was he never said
no he made you feel like you were eight
years old again and that first time an
adult treats you like an adult when
you're eight that was how you felt
around Stan he was the ultimate
gentleman and he made us each better
souls and thank you again for hosting
tonight and thank you all for being here
because it made me feel a little bit
less alone
[Music]
you know the stand a lot of people say
he cameo did Mallrats it really wasn't a
cameo it was a role it was a role and he
always felt that as well but without
like that x-men is the first cameo cameo
I believe of like the run that like
think about it you don't think of a
Marvel movie without that happening but
originally it happened in the x-men
movies and started and every time a
Marvel movie happened it was like Stan
was a part of it
yeah he wasn't him blade that's right
was he in any of the other blades like
two or three don't believe he was no
never popped up and blade they might
have been in Blade 3 which was after
x-men so maybe there was a we should
maybe put Stan in this but he wasn't in
the first one I was gonna say maybe had
a thing about r-rated movies but he was
in [ __ ] Deadpool and he was in
[ __ ] Mallrats
so yeah well it's weird man um but yeah
without Tom maybe we don't get that
[ __ ] run of cameos give it up for Tom
man well thanks John
[Applause]
they're you know the man wrote it and we
all know it with great power comes great
responsibility
Stanley had great power and he used it
very responsibly over the course of his
lifetime made a lot of us dreamers made
a lot of us true believers was the first
true believer and the first person who
waved the flag for this [ __ ] say it was
important and yeah sure on some level
was important because it was a bottom
line for a business that he was in but
you can't [ __ ] back something that
hard unless you believe in a little bit
he believed in what they were doing he
just didn't believe that it was all that
important it took generations and it
took billions of dollars that moveth the
box office to finally convince him like
yeah oh god it was important and you
know stan has a quote I'm not going to
do it justice but he's talked about like
you know I used to be embarrassed about
being a comic book writer you know I
wasn't a doctor I wasn't building
buildings I wrote comic books he's like
and then one day I realized
that entertainment was important
sometimes it's all somebody has from
keep him from going crazy and whatnot so
I started to you know tell people no I
write comic books he was the he was the
one who went out there first to be like
this shit's cool and I'm an adult saying
it he didn't talk down to his audience
he didn't when he was out there talking
about comics in the world he wasn't
dismissive like these are read by people
in their parents basements or anything
like that no man he made you feel like
you were part of something like you said
he branded he made a tribal he was like
you're with Marvel or not like it was
something to be a part of you know he
made you gave you shorthand
now kids don't have it so much in this
world right but he we had shorthand back
in the day because you knew if he likes
somebody if they liked what you liked
and if they liked Marvel if they knew
who Stan Lee was you knew you could hang
with that [ __ ] person I'm good for
things like you see stood and in a time
when people didn't often in letter
columns railing against racism railing
against fascism railing against you know
homophobia and bigotry and all of that
[ __ ] like he would go out and say if you
like Marvel Comics you're not that kind
of person because we don't believe that
here he went against the comics code
where there was a time when the comics
code of America said you have to abide
by certain rules and laws we have and we
don't want drug use in our comics
because we believe that children read
them we want to influence them in a bad
way and the comics code didn't want them
to do that they were gonna withhold
their approval and he said I want to do
this three issue one in spider-man where
somebody Odie's and I think it's
important and the code wouldn't certify
that [ __ ] the code and he published him
anyway and it became this sort of this
flag in the ground of here the things
that I believe in here's the things that
I and this company will stand for and
you know in a time when nobody else was
doing that in a time when it cost him
money to do that and so here's what I
believe it you know and doing so she
changed the world like we live in a
fundamentally Stanly world and without
him it wouldn't be the same world we
have for for for good or bad way less
bad than there was good but without him
we don't have this world today the
those Steve Jobs this big quote right
even put a dent in the universe make a
dent in the universe standed him away
better not stand created a universe and
left it behind for all of us to enjoy
for some very lucky few to play in we
know we talk about the movies a lot but
hey man it all starts right here on the
[ __ ] page I was lucky enough to get to
play with his [ __ ] characters so did
daredevil with casada and Jimmy Paul
Marathi joke asada and Jimmy Pavarotti
and made me contemporaries with Stan we
got to go to events with Stan and
[ __ ] you know stand shoulder to
shoulder with a guy who was vouching for
us as the next generation of comics and
whatnot yeah to say he was great is an
understatement to say he was spectacular
sensational marvelous uncanny uncanny
incredible fantastic amazing ultimate
true believer what yes 2099 let's leave
that off
new universe huh he was yeah that one
still stings he was all that and so much
more we are it's weird when people die
you know you're tend to say stuff like
this but [ __ ] I don't think I've ever
meant it as much as I mean it now we
will never see his like again
in this lifetime we'll maybe maybe
somewhere somewhere right now you know
somebody who can come close to Stanley's
legacy is being born but we won't see
that person flourish into what he became
we were very lucky to be born in the
second half of his life you know [ __ ]
to see all that to be there and reap the
benefits of everything that he sowed and
put together and whatnot
yeah but culture culture was wet clay
when he got there and at this point it's
hardened a bit and the chance to get in
there and get your [ __ ] hands dirty
and shape it into a thing that you
wanted to be that only you can see like
those those times are long gone like
there's there's nothing left to discover
on earth in the same way that there's
nothing left new Under the Sun when it
comes to culture in a very real way and
he was there when you still could you
built to one of the forefathers of pop
culture for heaven's sakes and that's
the culture that dominates more now than
anything else
you got something let's give you a mic
man we need a mic hold on it's coming on
back JC's got a mic what's your name
young camper will everyone give it up
for will
thanks you you remember watching the
spiderman cartoons every Saturday
morning amazing spider-man and Friends
yeah firestorm Firestar and Iceman yeah
and Stan they didn't realize that they
were all [ __ ] living there and being
heroes and save time but the narrator he
was hello spider friends this is Stan
Lee
yeah and he would introduce into the
commercial as he'd be like well be right
back after these messages
yes one day I was in the Starbucks in
Beverly Hills and I had a I had an
office over near wool shirt hold on here
comes the spare hello hello okay so
anyway I was I was standing in line
ordering I said you know I heard someone
back there said talking like that and it
was he was on his cell phone he was yeah
I'll be right back you know and he said
okay true belieber talk to you later I
turned around and it was Stan and I were
I remembered you know it's like a light
bulb it turned on inside your headed so
I just started talking to him next thing
I know I'm up in his office around the
corner and we you know I told him I said
you know they waited until Jim Henson
died to make a documentary on him and
they waited til a lot of creators died
and they don't really have a say when
the documentary is made so a documentary
on him so that's with great power the
stand back yea with great power you were
in and I don't know if you ever got a
DVD I'm for you you got a copy yeah just
I remember this in a couple years with
great power the Stan Lee story man we
met you at the at the UCLA event that's
when we started shooting yes that's
right I remember the after-party
afterwards I think is when I did an
interview right anyway I just said would
air on epics I see the epics logos that
were when epics picked it up for three
years and I can actually picked it up
for a few years but I don't want to self
plug it but it was I
plug it for you with great power the
Stanley story man can they find it on
Amazon yeah it's on Amazon and Vudu and
just building on what you were saying
earlier about Stan always given people a
chance and you know from the moment that
dialogue started he was just totally
open to it and sitting there and you
were just a guy he met it started some
random guy at Starbucks but that was
thanks that was a great way to like walk
into his life and just meet everybody
you know hanging out Sunday afternoons
up at the house with his wife and they
were telling the old stories from New
York and and you know that Hungary time
I guess he could say that he came out
here it wasn't easy it seems easy now
but there was like decades where he was
trying to get things going he came out
with the idea like I'm gonna go out to
Hollywood we're gonna sell Marvel
because they've been doing cartoons they
did The Incredible Hulk and stuff I
think I don't know if that has started
yet but he came out and I think they
live in the same house that they bought
their first sound hearing stuff I got a
good deal on it back then I'm sure and
wound up living next to Leonardo
DiCaprio right Stan would always tell a
story about like one day we were pulling
out this kid came running up to my car
and said I want to play you in a movie
and I said okay true believer and then
max told me it was Leonardo DiCaprio
go figure so I was down this trail the
story no but you know he he was just one
of those guys that you could open doors
for you and just get you to think on a
higher level so I I always you know and
if you say the right things they'll make
a movie with you yeah well I was I was
pushing for that before actually hope to
make a feature one day of his life to
tell that's it's got to be in the offing
you know at this point I mean even while
he was still here it was something that
would be talked about at one point
people were like oh it should be Bryan
Cranston he'd be amazing Stan later in
his life yes of course I hope to god
there's a stand biopic at one point you
know somebody's floating the notion of
doing like a Mad Men type series but set
at Marvel the bullpen or something like
that I was like oh my god I'd watch the
[ __ ] out of that man you know every week
they're creating a new [ __ ] legendary
character and we get to see the behind
the scenes and [ __ ] so I I'd be all for
it I'll watch anything they want to do
about Stan's life there's no way they'd
do it justice when nickeled the Nicholas
Hammond version of spider-man and then
the Lou Ferrigno Hulk and you know in
that time things would it seemed like
come together and then fall apart and
then he'd just keep trying and keep
trying it so that you know ongoing
charging kind of it so yeah it took him
like 30 years of selling his wares out
here and it gets some traction but
nothing like it is now and then one day
everybody just realized like oh [ __ ]
these would make great [ __ ] movies
came at the right time when you can pull
off the effects you can make Iron Man
look like it's really could pull off the
Hulk so it wasn't just a guy painted
green you can expand and kind of bring
like for the first time technology
matched the imaginations of a bunch of
guys from the 60s that's right you know
in Bank suddenly it's happening but [ __ ]
I would watch a movie and about his life
you know I'm looking forward to watching
this man
remember when this was going on give it
up for man he put Stan's life on film
[Applause]
can I say one last time salute I've been
watching Facebook the last couple of
days and a lot of people from those
years that I you know the cast and crew
from that experience you know they've
expressed a lot of loss and mourning and
I just wanted to you know say something
to recognize because I've times
experienced just you know meeting and
knowing stand for that small time some
people on the movie yeah the people that
either you know we got some of the cast
back here we got we got Nikki who is
also one of the co-director producers
and you know just there was a hundreds
of I've heard I think everything in the
last few days there were fake yeah I
myself have like received the texts as
if like the volume of text I received
like when well I didn't have a phone
back then this is the most text I've
ever received about a death since I've
been receiving texts yeah but to be fair
not a lot of people have died since I've
been receiving texts like my dad died
before texts were popular this is the
most that people have reached out to me
about somebody's death since my own
father's death and that's very telling
like [ __ ] people I haven't spoken to
in years or like when I saw that Stan
Lee died the first person I thought was
you or something which was very sweet
very touching but for some people they
just like they're like that's how I know
him cuz of you
like I didn't know who he was until he
made that movie and stuff and then some
people knew that like I looked up to him
you know but I tried to I tried to be
like him you know a carnival barker you
like the salesman I'm a salesman at
heart and I'm [ __ ] selling Kevin
Smith I'm in the Kevin Smith business he
was in the Marvel business yeah but you
know he believed it he sold with
sincerity he was
like a used car salesman or something
like that he believed in his product but
at the end of the day he was always
selling something but he did it was such
class and he treated every potential
customer or every past customer as if
the [ __ ] Sun was shining on him in
that moment they got all his [ __ ]
attention and I've tried to emulate that
my entire career like because he was so
[ __ ] good at he was so wonderful over
the crowd like I we could all hoped
Christ we age as well as Stan did that I
think that had a lot to do with living
out here I think if he had stayed in New
York each time I don't think he would
have made it to nine nearly 96 but like
he benefitted from moving out here both
him and Joanie Joanie lived a long time
as well I thought he was gonna be like
Gandalf and live to 112 exactly man
honestly there were days where I'm like
well like remember our mall rats they're
like be careful e73
if only we'd known that like oh you got
time like I'm gonna be here forever and
it made you think that he would be there
even longer I honestly like look I
almost [ __ ] died before Stan and that
would have made more sense to me than
the world that we're in now where I'm
here and he's not that hey it don't make
sense be it's certainly not [ __ ] fair
like its life should be a meritocracy
and if you create as much as he did and
you should [ __ ] live forever and I
guess he will yeah just not
[Music]
[Applause]
shall we head off into that good night
and I think we shall none of us want to
leave because we all warmed by the
[ __ ] familiarity we all share the
feeling we have right now for the guy
that we all loved and will continue to
love they'll be with us like the force
always and in the words of of a really
great guy who was really [ __ ]
talented and really appreciated
everything that came his way in life
let's end the way that he would always
like to end things nuff said
and excelsior you're right and it says
that is fat man on that fat man beyond
well done for this week man I'm Kevin
wait even though that ain't it did you
all enjoy yourselves ladies gentlemen do
you all feel a little bit better a
little bit better weird question to ask
at the end of a wake or eulogy but yes
we did all enjoy ourselves man there
ain't no show without the guy standing
am i right give it up for marvelous mark
bernard eddie and that is fat man on
Batman for there's no clock
god dammit dammit that is yoga horses
you gotta write a tissue it is yoga
horses debate I have to write it right
right over the camera that is fat man
beyond for this week man I'm Kevin Smith
I am our panel tune in next week same
fat time same fat channel spot gas calm
or YouTube that calm slash Kevin Smith
excelsior [ __ ] good night
you sound
[Applause]
flat
you